some people catch pokemon i catch
nutella hey guys i'm abby Sharpe welcome
to Abby's kitchen summer is winding down
but there are still a few solid
weekend's left to go out and enjoy one
of the fun fairs and carnivals in your
city and I think all cities have they're
special to you and it comes to those
crazy deep-fried foods but in my city of
Toronto it's all about the beat retail
come on
what is more Canadian than a fairy tale
so for my American viewers at home
you're probably wondering what the heck
is this thing well essentially what it
is is a big piece of dough the food
deep-fried loaded with cinnamon sugar
coated with lots of sugary syrups and
honestly I have been known to wait for
like an hour for one of these things at
the fair but pair that with a turn on
real world and it's not feeling so hot
so that's why I partnered up with my
friends at flat and flat breads to make
a better for you vegan deeper tale that
starts with natural almond butter fresh
fruit and of the image
not only is my version of lowering fat
from the original but the flat-out
flatbreads deliver 8 grams of fiber and
7 grams of protein per 140 calories wrap
carne food that you can actually feel
good about yeah I'm gonna want to be
signed up for that so first we're gonna
make this little vegan Nutella starts
with a cup of hazelnuts I just toasted
these lightly got most their skins off
and process them until they get to a
nice kind of ground up in that
consistency next I add in a little
unsweetened cocoa powder some coconut
sugar coconut oil and a good pinch of
salt
now we let this get nice
so I'm just gonna put a little bit of
coconut oil into my pan let it melt and
get hot or about a medium-high heat
bust into my flat outs so I'm just gonna
place my flat out down into my nonstick
skillet on about a medium-high heat and
we're just gonna let that get nice and
cold
sighs you're basically looking for it to
kind of bubble up and get all puffy all
around the edges that's when you know
it's time to flip beautiful I'm just
gonna drain this on a little piece of
paper towel and while it's still hot
this is really important
nails at times hit it with a little bit
of coconut sugar and cinnamon now we get
to decorate all right so first we're
gonna do a little layer of all-natural
almond butter as our base
then we're going in with our fruit so
I've got some beautiful ripe
strawberries and some sliced banana then
I've got some toasted pumpkin seeds some
toasted coconuts toasted almonds and a
nice bit of crunch from the countess
finally we're gonna finish with that
delicious
they'll address
so yes this totally is still a treat but
you get 10 grams of protein and 7 grams
of fiber in half of the butter tail I
mean talk about a win-win-win
no line ops no deep fryer no
embarrassing her little photo
immortalized in a twenty dollar souvenir
frame what's not to love right so guys
thank you so much for watching if you
like this video be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below with
some more favorite carny recipes
subscribe to the channel and I'll see
you next time on Abby's kitchen
don't you assure Canadian now I bet you
do